hi
i'm nicholas paul breiswitz the director
of development here at the long now
foundation
and i want to begin tonight's program by
letting you know how much we appreciate
your support for our work
long now is a non-profit organization
and every one of our projects and
programs is entirely funded by members
and donors like you
so thank you for helping us foster
long-term thinking
we believe that civilization scale
challenges call for this kind of
civilization scale thinking
and this has been an especially
challenging year for so many people
and so many organizations including ours
if you're able
please consider making a special
donation to our annual fundraising
campaign
you can make an online donation in just
minutes by visiting longnow.org
support by making a tax deductible gift
to the long now foundation
you'll not only be helping an
organization directly affected by this
civilization scale challenge
but you'll be helping us help everyone
get better at addressing all such
civilization scale challenges
learn more at longnow.org support and
please don't forget to ask your employer
if they have a charitable gift matching
program that could double
or even triple your impact on long-term
thinking thank you again for all your
support
enjoy the seminar hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
we are coming to you from the interval
here in san francisco where i'll be
joined by nadia ekbal
who'll be watching the edited version of
her talk with all of us as well as
staying on for questions afterwards
open source software makes up the
underpinning of much of the internet
as well as some of the longest running
software projects we have
nadia has been doing research into
digital infrastructure
and governance systems for many years
and her most recent book published by
stripe
press is called working in public and
that comes from interviews with hundreds
and hundreds of software developers over
several years
she's going to be sharing some of what
she learned with us today welcome
nadia ekbal thanks alexander everyone
likes to talk about writing software but
we don't talk enough about maintenance
we've all heard the stories of
developers toiling away in their dorm
rooms
launching their apps to millions of
users but the day-to-day life of a
software developer
is much less glamorous i've spent the
last five years trying to understand the
maintenance of open source software
open source refers to code that's freely
available for public use
open source developers write and publish
their code online with a license that
makes it possible for anyone to use or
modify their work
open source and its predecessor free
software have been around for more than
20 years
before that most software was made by
companies and sold with a private
license that meant nobody could do
anything with their code
when open source first came onto the
scene it was seen as this fringe
hobbyist experiment that would never
gain popular attraction
there's a quote from a young bill
gates's open letter to hobbyist in the
1970s where he asks
who can afford to do professional work
for nothing what hobbyist can put three
manures into programming
finding all bugs documenting his product
and distributing it for free
while bill gates was referring to the
mischievous developers who had pirated
microsoft's first software product basic
this same question has been asked of
open source developers who often
contribute to these projects in their
spare time
there's a lot of research out there as
to why open source developers create
software
but if i'm being honest i think those
answers are pretty clear to anyone who's
ever worked on something they love
why does anybody do anything for free
why do you paint or draw or write in
your spare time
the answers to those questions are not
so different from the reasons why a
developer might want to write code on
their nights and weekends and publish it
out in the open
and as it turns out a lot of developers
wanted to do this because today
the vast majority of all software we use
whether websites mobile apps or online
services
relies on open source code under the
hood even when software is privately
made by a company
such as instagram washington post or
youtube here the
developers employed by that company will
find code online that's open source
like the web framework django in this
case and then put it in their own
software
if you're watching this on youtube
you're relying on open source right now
in this way
open source forms the bones of our
digital infrastructure that undergirds
all of our daily activities not unlike
the roads and bridges that keep us
together in our physical world
understanding the maintenance costs of
this infrastructure then is key to
understanding how to care for our
digital future
you can see why the making part of
software would dominate the conversation
in open source
it's strange and compelling to think of
our entire digital world propped up by
the work of volunteer developers
who write open source because they enjoy
it but as it turns out
writing new code is only one small part
of maintaining software
in reality the majority of time spent on
software is not on making but
maintenance
which makes up by some estimates
somewhere around 50 to 70 percent of a
typical software developer's work
and yet curiously much less conversation
has been spent on understanding the
maintenance of software
if you're familiar with open source
already you know that it runs on
contributions from developers all over
the world
a developer writes and publishes their
project online initially but once it's
up
anyone can contribute to it by
submitting changes to the project these
changes are reviewed by that original
developer
or by any other number of so-called
maintainers that they've recruited and
either accepted or declined
if you've ever used google docs it's
like suggesting edits where someone else
with edit permissions decides whether
your suggestion will make it in
from an economics perspective
researchers typically explain open
source like this
developers are intrinsically motivated
to make and contribute to software
because they like hacking away on new
ideas
they share that code because they get
reputational rewards for showing off
their ideas
and software like other kinds of
information is zero marginal cost
meaning that the cost to produce it
doesn't increase with more users
said another way if i write and publish
my code on github the popular hosting
platform for open source projects
it should make no difference to me
whether 10 or 10 000 people want to use
it
the cost to me as a developer is the
same while this all sounds great in
theory
in practice economists are basically
saying that software doesn't have any
maintenance costs
or perhaps that maintenance is just as
intrinsically motivating and therefore
just as free as creation
but we know this just isn't true all
software does carry hidden ongoing
marginal costs
just not ones that people like to talk
about remember that it's not just that
anybody can use the project but that
anybody can contribute to it
and reviewing contributions takes work
like any leader or organizer
only a maintainer can see across the
whole project to understand how those
contributions will fit in
this coordination work to put it bluntly
is not nearly as fun as writing code
because it means maintainers are dealing
with a bunch of other strangers code
which as you can imagine is a varying
quality
think about the quality of the average
comment section on the internet and then
imagine you have to respond to every
single one of those commenters
and you'll get an idea of what
maintainers often deal with on their
projects
while creating new software is
intrinsically motivated maintaining
software tends to be drudger's thankless
work
where as one open source developer
benjamin lupton puts it
creation is an intrinsic motivator but
maintenance usually requires extrinsic
motivation
software developers are about as excited
about maintaining old software as most
people are about fixing their roof
you do it because you have to but not
because you love doing it
this is a graph of the number of commits
or code contributions
per contributor made to bootstrap a
popular design framework used by an
estimated 20
of all websites as you can see the
number one contributor makes
significantly more contributions than
the long tail
bootstrap officially lists over a
thousand contributors to the project
today
which makes it seem like a community
project but most of those people have
only contributed once ever
whereas just three developers have
authored about three quarters of those
commits and that's just code committed
to the project which is usually the most
exciting kind of contribution
user support which pretty much nobody
wants to do is a whole other ball game
on top of this
user support is a significant marginal
cost of software not just for open
source projects but even big software
companies
as a maintainer if 10 000 people use my
open source project i will notice a
difference compared to having just 10
users
i'll notice that in the form of more
users and contributors submitting issues
bug reports and questions
and as we can see here the number of
maintainers doesn't necessarily grow
proportionately to your popularity
developers didn't feel the pain of this
in the early days of the internet
because there were just fewer people
using open source software
but at today's scale these maintenance
costs become much more serious
to put this in perspective at the time
of the early open source movement
there were just over 200 000 registered
users on sourceforge which was the
popular code hosting platform at the
time
today there are 40 million users on
github its modern successor
a 200x increase over the last 20 years
and that number has more than tripled in
just the past four years
the community dynamic that we're used to
thinking of with open source where you
essentially have a hobbyist club of
developers using and contributing
together
doesn't work at this size instead you're
more likely to see a few maintainers
running the project
with a huge audience of developers who
are using but not contributing to your
project
most so-called contributors are just
casual or one-time contributors
and see themselves more as users than
members of the project's community
just as you might find it difficult to
have nuanced conversations with an angry
random stranger on twitter
a maintainer finds it hard to
collaborate with an angry random
stranger on github
faced with a high volume of low quality
conversations like any of us who are
dealing with too many notifications or
too many emails
maintainers have to prioritize who they
respond to now you might ask
is it just possible to reduce the
maintenance cost of software
to decrease the burden that these
maintainers are experiencing
yes to an extent but there are limits
for two big underlying reasons
the first is that code once it's
published and once it finds a set of
users
never really dies because someone out
there is probably going to keep using
your software for an unreasonably long
time
software moves quickly and so it's often
thought of as fleeting or ephemeral
your favorite website disappears
overnight or you log into twitter to
find that your news feed has suddenly
changed
by contrast our physical world moves at
a slower clumsier pace
the road in front of your house were to
be repaved or someone knocked down one
of your office walls to build a new wing
the jack hammering and scaffolding and
the smell of paint would give you weeks
and months of warning as things change
but software only appears to be
ephemeral from the user's perspective
not the developers software's roots run
deep and the maintenance of software can
extend over years or even decades on a
much longer time scale
a lot of developers know the
difficulties of making software
compatible
across different browser versions and
mobile platforms
chris zacharias a developer who worked
at youtube once described the pain of
having to support users who were still
using a really old version of internet
explorer
he called ie6 the quote bane of our web
development team's existence
stealing time from other important
projects and yet despite that pain his
team was told they had to continue
supporting it
one day as chris tells the story he and
his team were sitting around in the
cafeteria exhausted from not having
slept enough the night before
and they began to quote collectively
fantasize about how they could exact
their revenge on ie6
they decided to put up a banner on
youtube displayed to ie6 users that said
we will be phasing out support for your
browser soon please upgrade to one of
these more modern browsers
the statement wasn't actually true and
they didn't tell any of the company
about their plan
they were just sick of having to
maintain youtube for ie6 users
but their plan worked within a month
youtube's ie6 user base had dropped by
half and they were finally able to
relieve themselves of their maintenance
burden
some of the oldest code ever written is
still running in production today
the programming languages fortran and
cobol were both released in the late
1950s
this is fortran being used on a punch
card while you won't really hear new
software developers clamoring to learn
these languages
both are still in active use today and
not in half forgotten software
applications but embedded in critical
pieces of our social infrastructure
fortran for example is used in
scientific computing like weather and
climate modeling
while cobalt is widely used in
government healthcare and financial
systems
including adp the popular payroll
service the second thing to know about
software is that you can never really
finish maintaining it either
software might be feature complete
meaning that nothing else needs to be
built or added
but in order to continue running
software requires some sort of ongoing
maintenance
because it depends on other people's
code to run successfully and other
people's code keeps changing
i previously talked about software's
hidden marginal costs such as the rising
cost of user support as a project
becomes more popular
but software also has temporal costs
meaning that it requires ongoing
maintenance to continue running
successfully
regardless of how many people use it
rather than a function of use
these costs are a function of entropy or
the inevitable decay of systems over
time
when i think about temporal costs i
think of the golden gate bridge in san
francisco
whose function hasn't changed in the
past near century that it's been around
but it still requires repainting safety
checks and regular cleaning to protect
it against the elements
in software the equivalent of those
costs might include things like
rewriting code upgrading to modern tools
and services
and removing old dependencies code is
cleanest when it's first released
because that's when developers are
thinking about the project holistically
and writing it from scratch
but as more code gets added to the
project over time it starts to become a
bit of a mishmash
open source projects are particularly
susceptible to the so-called technical
debt
more so than close source software
because open source maintainers accept
contributions from developers who might
not necessarily know each other
or have full context for the project
unlike developers who are working
together at the same company
thus far i focus on how maintenance
costs can be a negative or somewhat
draining cost for developers
but there's also an argument to be made
that maintenance costs are necessary to
keep projects alive and pass them down
from generation to generation
the ise grand shrine is a shinto shrine
in japan that's torn down and rebuilt
every 20 years a practice that's
continued for more than 1200 years now
this practice of tearing down and
rebuilding serves a real purpose
which is not only to keep the shrine
looking fresh and new but also to pass
down the techniques of construction to
future generations similarly software
requires
tearing down and reconstruction to keep
the tradition of building alive
fergus henderson is a longtime software
engineer at google who once wrote about
google's internal processes
and according to fergus most software at
google gets rewritten every few years
he gave a few reasons for this the first
being that product requirements change
to keep up with modern technology and
changing user preferences
but he also points out that rewriting
software has positive benefits for their
organization
like trimming down unnecessary code
complexity as well as transferring
knowledge and a sense of ownership to
newer team members
so there are a lot of good reasons why
software is never done
like the easy grand shrine it's a
process that never ends and one that
involves passing knowledge from one
generation to another
despite its challenges software
maintenance shouldn't be considered a
problem per se
it's just a part of the ecological life
cycle and so this gets to a really
interesting aspect of software which is
that it can exist in either a static or
active state
and it's important to make this
distinction and know which state we're
talking about when we consider the
question of maintenance
coden's static state is like lumber it's
a dead commodity that can be bought and
sold and traded
when we access code in a static state
we're thinking about it on the basis of
pure consumption
the implication is that we can inspect
it for historical purposes but is not
being used anywhere today
but most useful software and useful
meaning relevant to humans on earth in
this present moment
is by definition code that lives in an
active state
code that's in an active state like c is
like a living tree or a forest
code in active state depends on other
things and other things depend on it to
survive
this isn't so different from how any
other form of knowledge works
an old book that's collecting dust in a
library that no one has read or heard of
isn't very useful to society today
because no one's really using it
the ideas inside the book aren't running
in production they're being stored on a
shelf
one day someone might rediscover those
ideas and work it into modern
conversations giving them new meaning
but until then those books live in an
archival state waiting to be discovered
but some books are still frequently
discussed and cited today despite their
age
the bible for example is a book that
lives in an active state because it's
widely read and referenced by millions
of people around the world
code is like that as well some code
collects dust and static state while
other code is in active use today
a software developer named jacob
thornton made a similar observation
about open source a few years ago
jacob is one of the creators of the
popular design framework bootstrap whose
contribution graph i showed you at the
beginning of this talk and before i
share his comment a lot a bit of context
which is that richard stallman
a long-time programmer who started the
free software movement
which was open source's predecessor
famously said that free software is free
as in speech
but not free as in beer stallman was
trying to make the distinction between
the idea of
being free as in liberated versus free
as in zero cost
sometimes expressed with the spanish
words libre versus gratis
a distinction that's meant to highlight
how free software is an ideology
rather than about getting software for
free so
jacob rift on this concept and he tried
to explain the problem of open source
requiring ongoing maintenance
jacob said that open source is free not
as in beer or speech
but free as in puppy i think this
metaphor is really good because it
forces us to think of software not as a
static object like beer but instead
consider the cost associated with its
being a living organism like a puppy
you don't just buy a puppy and put it in
your house and be done with it like you
could with a beer in the fridge
you have to feed it and take care of it
and make sure it's happy
getting a puppy much like writing
software signifies the beginning
not the end of a new chapter and with it
comes all these hidden costs associated
with its upkeep
open source's predecessor the free
software movement was explicitly about
maximizing legal and social freedoms for
the code itself
the four essential freedoms of free
software which were first published by
richard stallman in 1986
refer to the freedoms of code not of the
people who write the code
again they're called the four freedoms
of free software not the four freedoms
of software developers
the last 20 years have nearly nothing to
offer about how open source is actually
made and maintained
in fact there's shockingly little
vocabulary out there that describes how
open source projects and communities
might differ from each other
it's like if we only had one word
business to describe everything from a
mom and pop shop to a fortune 100
company
and by treating software as an object we
abstract away its true nature
the way in which it's tightly integrated
with living social systems
and therefore ignore its hidden costs
this comes at a cost to open source
developers happiness and well-being
where they're expected to maintain
software basically forever
even though in many cases they don't get
any intrinsic or extrinsic benefit from
it
to go back to bill gates's question from
the beginning of this talk
who can afford to do professional work
for nothing
we rarely use code as a static object
even though from an economic perspective
we still value it that way
code like other types of information is
not a book or a file or a cd
even if it occasionally appears in that
format in each of these cases the
physical version is a form of artificial
scarcity that's meant to help us assign
a value to the underlying information
but the information itself exists
independently of any of these physical
formats
the author neil stevenson once described
the operating system unix as
quote not so much a product as it is a
painstakingly compiled oral history of
the hacker subculture
it is our gilgamesh epic unix is known
loved and understood by so many hackers
that it can be recreated from scratch
whenever someone needs it
code in its truest form is not a product
to be bought and sold so much as a
living form of knowledge and oral
history
so how then could we value code in this
living contextual ecosystemic
relationship
by looking at the people who produce it
human relationships are a way to
understand
the true value of code who maintains
that code and why we trust them to
maintain it
while this might seem strange at first
it's not so different from how we think
about valuing cities
infrastructure and other systems of
human complexity the author jane jacobs
offered a similar approach in our 1961
book the death and life of great
american cities where she criticized the
contemporary 1950s approach to urban
planning
according to jacobs urban planners
treated cities as static objects
considering how they should be developed
only at the time of creation
rather than continuously revising their
plans according to how people use them
the urban ministry practitioner douglas
hall describes this as the cat and the
toaster problem in his book of the same
name
douglas said that churches neighborhoods
cities and cultures are complex and
interrelated living social
systems they're like cats but as he puts
it we've grown accustomed to thinking of
our social context not as living systems
but as objects we can easily measure and
control
like a toaster but the problem is that
we still tend to think and talk about
software as a static object
taking it out of context it's why we
have this myth that software is zero
marginal cost
ignoring the complex human
interdependencies that are required to
maintain it
we treat software like toasters instead
of cats
and so the value of open source
infrastructure doesn't lie
entirely in the code itself sure we can
say that some code is better written
than others or that it solves an
important problem
but over time what was once a
groundbreaking solution might become
commonplace
or it was once an elegant piece of code
is now a bit out of fashion
right now we only seem to know how to
value knowledge based on its first copy
costs or that initial cost of creation
it's why we always talk about creating
software but rarely about maintaining it
it's why open source culture focuses on
the intrinsic motivation that drives a
developer to create
but not the extrinsic rewards that are
actually needed to continue maintaining
software
and this isn't a dig on anyone by the
way it's hard to figure out the answers
to these problems
while researching my book i tried to
understand how we appraise the economic
value of public infrastructure today
like parks and bridges and it turns out
there's very little information out
there
probably because so much of our physical
infrastructure is made and maintained by
governments
but we don't have a government of the
internet and if we consider not just
our so-called hard infrastructure
meaning the physical networks that keep
society running
but also our soft infrastructure meaning
social norms culture
arts and institutions that give our
society meaning
this question of how to value our
digital infrastructure doesn't just
apply to software developers but to
anyone who's engaged in the creation
distribution and maintenance of content
today
but if we want to understand how to
support the ongoing maintenance of
software
or any kind of content we have to start
with this idea that its value lies not
in the actual code anymore but in the
people who write the code
in economic terms open source software
is frequently referred to as a public
good
but public goods are to use two fancy
terms non-rivalrous and non-excludable
non-rivalrous means that my use of the
good doesn't diminish your ability to
consume it
think about breathing air versus cutting
down a forest non-excludable means that
i can't prevent anyone else from
accessing the good
think of a public park that anyone can
enter instead of an amusement park that
charges admission
and so open source is non-excludable
because it's freely available for anyone
to use and that's one of its core tenets
but it seems that open source is not
exactly non-rivalrous because as we've
already seen
there are marginal costs that are still
associated with maintaining software so
is open source code still a public good
yes but the solution i'd like to propose
is that open source is not really one
economic good after all
but two different kinds of goods
masquerading as one open source code is
a public good
it's a static object that anyone can
access and use without diminishing
anyone else's ability to use it
these days a thousand people can happily
copy paste your code if they want it
without affecting another person's
ability to use it but the production of
open source code
meaning the people behind the code
functions more like a commons
a comment is a resource that's owned
used and managed by a community
a lake or a forest would be an example
of a commons where if everyone chopped
down all the trees or overfished the
lake
there wouldn't be anything left of the
resource this creates a so-called
tragedy of the commons that you might be
familiar with
where everyone acts in their own
self-interest instead of the common good
and thus depletes the resource the
production of code is a commons where
the attention of maintainers is the
depletable resource
it might not cost a contributor anything
to open an issue or ask a question
and they might even genuinely be trying
to help but if a single maintainer
receives 100 of these requests
that they need to review and respond to
eventually their limited attention will
be depleted because there are only so
many hours in the day
so even though the contributor can't
always see the way in which their
request depletes the attention commons
each new interaction does diminish a
maintainer's ability to interact with
another contributor
if we accept this conception of open
source then maintainers hold a special
place in this ecosystem
in conservation biology terms materials
can be thought of as a keystone species
a keystone species is small in
population size but it has an outsized
impact on its ecosystem
if you imagine a forest for example
there might not be that many wolves in
absolute numbers
but if the wolves disappeared there
would be cascading effects on the rest
of the forest
the deer population lacking a natural
predator would grow out of control the
plants would start to disappear because
there would be too many deer and so on
similarly although maintainers are few
in number their impact on an open source
project is far-reaching
because they're the bottleneck to
everyone else's contributions
if a maintainer disappears it's possible
that someone will eventually take their
place and a lot of times that is what
happens
but a project can't survive without
somebody stepping up into that
maintainer's role
if a project doesn't have any
maintainers there's nobody available to
coordinate review and merge
contributions it literally cannot go on
and so valuing open source software and
the maintenance work involved requires
that we transition away from this idea
of
code as an object to be bought and sold
which is the language of what we used to
call
information goods and towards
relationship based ways of thinking
about the code and content we consume
we can ask ourselves if this person
steps down or disappears will the value
of the project be materially impacted
if so why aren't we talking more about
supporting that person
to me there is no concept of software
without people
like any type of infrastructure open
source is meaningless without
understanding its present value to human
civilization
we have to appraise its value in terms
of the people who depend on it and the
people who maintain it
an empty city without any people is a
chilling concept to me
but in many ways free and early open
source culture is defined by this focus
on software as an object
software without any people that stands
the test of time
it's a beautiful concept but i don't
think it's actually how complex
knowledge systems work
it's like the urban planners of the
1950s that jacob's criticized
the idea that you can construct a
building once and forget about it or
write code and forget about it
simply isn't a realistic vision of
what's required to make and move these
systems
software is brittle unreliable subject
to breakage at all times and endless
exercise in patience and failing over
and over again
the developers i talked to seem very
aware that all of software
and by extension our entire digital
society is built on toothpicks and
popsicle sticks
that software is always one undiscovered
bug away from a critical failure
that what makes it work is not just the
disembodied algorithms that mainstream
media loves to write about
but one quiet dedicated person who's
frantically trying to fix your problems
on a saturday night
those are the images of open source that
stick with me stories about developers
who are thanklessly maintaining software
in these extremely prosaic ways
staying up late at night reading your
issues and trying to understand what's
going on
pushing a fix for a critical security
vulnerability before anyone exploits it
and so i think understanding the
maintenance problem of open source means
bringing developers out from behind the
scenes and back into the spotlight again
the focus on the volunteer communal
aspect of open source makes it sound
like it's about people
but remember again that free software is
explicitly founded to liberate code from
people
and so talking about this communal
nature of open source an
idealized world where people are highly
substitutable and anyone can swap in and
out of maintainership
firstly not only does it reflect what's
really happening on the ground
but also tends to come at the expense of
maintainers themselves
these are the people who've been
entrusted with shepherding our digital
futures
and i think it's a role that should be
treated with more reverence
maintenance is the work that goes into
constantly updating our priors
shaping and smoothing an idea that's
falling out of touch with today's
environment
making sense of a static object in our
current time and space
although maintainer is a term that's
commonly used to describe this role in
an open source project
i actually find it to be kind of
unappealing as the writer berner hobart
put it
running a successful open source project
is just good while hunting in reverse
where you start out as a respected
genius and end up being a janitor who
gets into fights it's no fun to be a
maintainer
as a creator you're working on a problem
that you're excited by that you're
intrinsically motivated to make progress
on
as a maintainer you're well a janitor
for your code who gets into fights with
strangers who have strong opinions about
how you should run your project
there's a newer project called room that
offers a set of tools for front-end
software development
one nice thing to note about this
project is that instead of calling their
leaders maintainers they call them
stewards
i think steward is a much nicer way to
highlight what exactly maintainers do
for these projects
they're stewards of the land protecting
a depletable resource which is the
attention commons of open source
a question i keep coming back to is how
do we make maintenance seem not quite so
dredgerous but actually appealing
how do we treat the role of code
stewardship with the reference it
deserves
maintainers are not only cradling our
fragile digital infrastructure in their
hands today
but like the maintainers of the isse
grand shrine they're constantly building
and rebuilding
it's a task that seems futile in the
moment but is actually an act of shaping
civilization
handing off her present knowledge to
future generations to come
thanks for having me and looking forward
to questions
thank you so much nadia um i believe
we're gonna
patch you in from where you are in st
parts watching the talk today
welcome hi thank you for having me it's
great to have you
um i'll get started with some questions
then we'll um we'll bring in questions
both from our audience as well as i know
stuart brand who's writing his current
book on maintenance of kind of
everything and i know this is one of his
chapters is on on software so i know he
has several questions as well as kevin
kelly
um but i think you know this idea of
uh you know how open source code is as
much about the community of maintainers
as individual creators
and can you say a bit more about how
this
this model really works in practice i
mean it seems like people who write the
code kind of then begrudgingly
maintain it um and i think people kind
of have this strange assumption that by
releasing it as open source that
somebody else is going to uh is going to
maintain it but that doesn't seem to be
the case it really seems to that the
the original coders are the ones behind
it yeah
that's right i think there's um there's
this sort of understanding of open
source
that hasn't really scaled with the times
where we
do think about these really big
well-known open source projects and they
do
definitely exist out there where they do
have hundreds of active contributors
you might think of something like linux
that has a lot of different
groups of maintainers for the projects
but then there's this very long tale of
open source projects that are
smaller in scope but still very very
widely used
and a lot of those only really end up
having one or a couple of maintainers on
the project
and there are a lot of reasons why
perhaps certain projects don't end up
attracting more contributors but i think
it's worth highlighting that
that is um that is a a
valid type of project to exist not all
open source projects end up
attracting this large community of
contributors but then that means that
all the work ends up falling on one or a
few maintainers
and i think it's the the language that
we have around open source right now as
being
extremely volunteer based sometimes
obscures the fact that there are
um a few specific contributors like in
the example of bootstrap
bootstrap that i mentioned in the talk
where it is
extremely widely used and they might
list a thousand contributors to the
project
um over the life of the project but
really it does come down to a couple of
these individuals who are sort of like
the keystone species of the project
and so i it feels like it requires a
little bit of a deeper look as to like
who are those maintainers and um
how are they stewarding the project
thanks and so i mean why do we have open
source like where does it fit
in this space i mean i think you you
started with this quote from bill gates
who obviously seemed confounded by the
fact that it could exist
um and i know that it underpins so much
of the internet
and so much of the infrastructure that
we rely on like why
why does it exist versus uh why would we
just not wait for a commercial effort
yeah at risk of being a little bit
cliche i was very um
guided and inspired by this idea from a
brand of information wanting to be free
but also wanting to be expensive and i
think
what happened to open source over the
last 20 years has really kind of
highlighted that
where uh open source code became a thing
because people just wanted to share
their code it's like any other type of
information where
of course we want to be able to release
it we want other people to use our stuff
we want them to
remix it and put it into their own
software and people can't help
themselves they want that to happen
right we can't really constrain
information and prevent it from being
shared around
but then on the other hand we see these
long-term effects of what's happening in
open source where
it's you know making that information
free doesn't mean that it doesn't come
with any sort of cost over time
and so open source is actually expensive
to maintain and right now we don't have
a very clear business model for
how does open source get maintained in
the way that software that's
shepherded by a company might have a
business model behind it
and so i think that's sort of the the
open question that people are still
trying to address right now
and um the the point that i wanted to
make about
how open source might really be two
types of economic goods is meant to sort
of address this question of
open source on the one hand being
something that can be freely shared
around
as a static piece of information without
incurring more costs
but when a lot of people are trying to
contribute to a project and contribute
in maybe these
lower value or more extractive ways
then it's not you know it's not actually
really costless to maintain so we have
to kind of think about
information being shared around as a
different sort of
economic good as information that is
being actively contributed to and shaped
and do you think it's important that
certain types of software be
open source versus certain types of
software being uh
being commercial and and not open source
i mean it seems like
we have a lot of these kind of shared
commons uh pieces of software ranging
from i mean
whether it's software or at least
contributor based things like wikipedia
and then on into linux that clearly they
have some
very special space in um in the kind of
deeper
infrastructure of what we do rather than
uh you know
i think there's a reason why you know no
commercial version of wikipedia ever
ever made it um and in a way some of
these uh some of these underpinnings of
of the kind of the very deep source code
behind servers
do you think there's a there's a reason
and importance behind that distinction
yeah it's interesting when i started
looking into this space
something that stood out to me was that
open source is frequently discussed
in the at the sort of more mainstream
level mostly in terms of
its end user applications and so we
think about
software applications that are directed
at consumers something like firefox for
example that is open source
and to me there's very little discussion
around the idea of open source
infrastructure like you you mentioned um
linux or other projects that are sort of
behind the software that we might
consume as users so even if the facebook
app itself
is not necessarily open source
facebook uses plenty of open source in
the making of that application
and i think they do have sort of like
two different paths or use cases
um i'm personally less i guess
interested in deeply understanding the
open source as a in terms of its sort of
end user
application um use because i think it
just raises different questions around
i don't think open source necessarily
has a clear advantage in being
open source for the consumer but it's
more interesting to think about open
source code that's available for
developers
because if you think of this sort of
like wide community of developers even
if they're not collaborating on the same
projects
but just sort of like anyone who might
theoretically need to use code to make
something happen in the world
all of those developers are going to be
wanting to share and trade around
ideas and knowledge that might be
expressed in the form of code and so
it's very hard to think about
uh it seems like it would be a
disadvantage to prevent that from
happening it's
why we have other forms of
infrastructure that are also public
goods it's just more efficient to
actually share that information around
whereas on the end user application side
it's a little bit harder to make
the case because um i think for a lot of
the reasons that we do see in open
source more
more generally which is just that it is
really hard to maintain
um and to find a business model for that
that kind of maintenance so
i do feel like there hasn't been enough
conversation around open source
as infrastructure and why it's so
necessary for
our entire digital society right
yeah i always find it interesting that
um you know it seems that there's an
inverse proportion of how much money you
pay for software
versus how well it works um and so you
know i mean i've worked with
you know quarter million dollar seats of
software for 3d modeling for instance
that
if you do if you don't also have the
maintenance contract that costs tens of
thousands of dollars with that company
it's basically unusable whereas things
that are basically given to you for free
either as web applications or as open
source software they seem to actually
work
infinitely better and and then don't
have this problem
can you talk a little bit about that
about this um where we're free
and or at least free as in puppy uh
moves to uh quarter million dollar
uh a year seats yeah i mean i think at
least on the infrastructure side it's
sort of resilient when you look at it
from this zoomed out perspective
um not thinking about any one specific
project but sort of like
what is that entire fabric of open
source
uh infrastructure that any one developer
might need access to
and so there are projects that sort of
die over time or the maintainer
disappears and
no one can you know the project is no
longer being updated anymore
and if you eventually get to that point
where people are still relying on this
project but no one is really
is is contributing to it or maintaining
it then there will be a point where
developers say well i think we should
start a different project and
then they might fork that project or
they might start a similar kind of
project and then
sort of encourage everyone to start
using that other project instead
and so it does you do see this sort of
like ecological life cycle that that
happens
where i don't think anyone will really
be
um i don't think i worry about some
worst case scenario where
there's like no open source available
because people decide they just don't
want to do it anymore
but then i sort of like zoom in on any
one specific project and i think about
well what is that mattiner going through
why did they disappear and
um what was their experience maintaining
the project and i just
have heard from so many maintainers that
have had less than ideal experiences and
it's sort of
unfortunate to me that a lot of them
kind of end up in this circumstance
where they're like
um so unhappy with the project that they
feel like they kind of need to disappear
or ghost and it seems like
that's not really the way that we should
be
rewarding people that are providing
something of such great value to
society it's it's sort of sad that they
just sort of you know drop off over time
um and so i think like sharing some of
those stories and bringing some
awareness around that might um
just help bring a little more reverence
to that role that i think they deserve
well i think that's a great place
um and we'll be pulling stuart uh
brandon after
after this but i think it's it's really
interesting um you know there's many
projects that like long now has worked
on really where
we found an open source project that was
the beginning it was kind of the right
thing
that we wanted but then has been lost in
maintenance
um but then you know we could maybe
offer some money
to that person to start to do an update
to it
and i i'm curious as to how you feel
about where
where paid work comes into open source i
know there's thousands of paid
contributors to various
especially the large open source
projects from various companies
but that interplay of paid open source
versus uh
you know kind of free hobbyist open
source
yeah it's a really complex topic um and
one that i think there aren't
necessarily clear answers to but just
sort of like
um signposts or directions that we could
take with it
historically it seems like a lot of
open source projects had to be very big
or very scaled out in order to attract
any sort of
paid development work um and you would
see these entities set up
say like a software foundation that
would become a companion to an open
source project and
that foundation might be sponsored by a
bunch of different companies and then
they kind of decide like
uh who gets to work on the project for
in a certain kind of like paid setup
now that we have a more fractured open
source landscape and that happened for a
lot of different reasons but
um kind of the the end result being that
we instead of having
a couple of these very monolithic
projects we have a lot of sort of
smaller fragmented projects which is
not dissimilar to what happened to a lot
of different types of content on the
internet
these projects are often too small to
really justify having some sort of
centralized entity or foundation that's
backing the project
but you still have like one developer
that is trying to figure out how to get
paid for their
work and so i think it especially starts
to highlight this shift towards
not just thinking about any one specific
project but thinking about the developer
who's behind that project because you'll
sometimes see it's one developer who's
just
you know especially creative or prolific
and might have created multiple projects
there are some
developers who have created hundreds or
even thousands of projects that are used
by other developers and so
the question might not be how do i
support this one project but how do i
support this person who's maintaining a
lot of different types of projects and
so i think the big shift that we're
seeing
in this question around people being
paid for open source work
is not just thinking about how do we pay
for a specific project but how do we
think about
sponsoring or supporting a specific
developer
and i was really happy to see github
last year released their sponsors
product to allow more people to sponsor
open source developers or any sort of
developer on github
and they when they launched it they they
made it about sponsoring developers and
not just about projects i think to help
encourage
some of that shift um culturally that we
we sort of need to like readjust to when
thinking about what it means to
to pay someone yeah nice yeah we worked
with github a little bit on their
long-term
uh kind of archive repository that they
put on svalbard in the last year
um just as a as an advisor on the kind
of format and all that but i thought it
was
it was a good effort to see that they're
there after kind of figuring out
the long-term future of code and for
people who don't know github is kind of
the largest
open source repository of of of code
that people generally use as the
platform by which they share their code
and their
and their commits to that code how do
you see uh
open source changing as a modern
ecosystem where is it now and where is
it going do you think there's a there's
a trajectory in the way this is working
yeah i think um a little bit of what i
touched on previously around i think the
biggest shift going from
thinking about projects and thinking
about sort of like the code or the
output or the
the product that is being created um
shifting from that to thinking about the
people behind the projects and
i've been really heartened to see in the
past few years and increase focus on
talking about maintainers and not just
sort of like this faceless group of
volunteers that we just assume is gonna
take care of code into um into
perpetuity and
um so i think there's a lot more of
these questions around um
what does it mean to support the
individuals that are working on open
source code
so i think that's a pretty major shift
and then
just from both a software and a social
standpoint this fragmentation that i
mentioned of
it's not just a couple of big projects
anymore but
because so many people are participating
in open source now and
the way that open source is now consumed
and distributed
you might have a specific software
project that is pulling in hundreds of
dependencies from
other open source projects and and so
it's a lot easier to just say oh i want
this
sort of like small snippet of code i'm
going to put into my project um
more so than in the past and github has
definitely helped facilitate that as
well and so you can think of it as
maybe like the breakdown from people
used to only write books all the time
and then like
they wrote maybe like articles or blog
posts and now people write tweets and so
it's like slowly getting more broken
down but it also means
again that i think the um the shift is
not just about
the the piece of content itself but the
the person who's behind it and so you
might similarly think about
people share around tweets often without
really even knowing who's behind the
thing
and so it becomes just a very different
relationship between like how
i as a consumer and perceiving my
relationship to um
to a small piece of code or to a tweet
or any other sort of
bite-sized piece of content and so i
think it brings in a really
interesting aspect now around the the
reputational questions and i think um
it's been harder to really like measure
that or make it legible in the world of
open source
of what is a developer's reputation and
github has sort of
made some attempts of that early early
on but i think has
still a long way to go in understanding
like what is the value of this developer
who's making this contribution on my
project because
two two different contributions are not
necessarily the same in value for me as
a
maintainer
and so i think we'll just be hearing a
lot more of that
uh and similarly in any other sort of
creator ecosystem right now where people
are interested in understanding the
reputation of the the person who's
behind the code or any other sort of
content that we create
excellent thank you i think we are able
to bring in stuart brand now
okay is this any better there you are
yes
it's great to hear you all right i love
your book love this talk and you're
really
going after some fundamental stuff here
um
i'm curious since the book has come out
which is just a few months ago but this
is a fast-moving field
um as response to the book and uh
the talks you've been giving and so on
uh have you come across
things basically um that you're now
adding to what you have to say about all
this
oh gosh i haven't been able to even
i think i'm gonna have to process it in
a in a few months
um it's been interesting to see just
sort of like the different
concepts that people pick up on and the
ones that they sort of want to
drill more into because you never really
know i guess when you when you release a
book of um
which things are going to resonate with
people versus not and
i've been very excited to have a lot of
conversations with folks about
this section of the book that focuses on
different community types
um stemming from different types of open
source projects so i mentioned in this
talk tonight that we have
this one term open source project to
describe every kind of project
which is like saying the the term
business to refer to every kind of
business like there are a lot of
different kinds of businesses
and there are a lot of different kinds
of projects and that was something that
i've struggled with in
my research over the years and wanted to
kind of put some shape around in
in the book and so i did propose a few
different uh
ways of describing different types of
open source projects and suggesting
what does that mean for different types
of online communities and so there's
been a lot of
very fruitful conversation around that
and that's been a lot of fun to have i
didn't
sometimes i guess like i i worry i was
like oh gosh i hope people like
you know you you like write the book and
you're like i hope that um this actually
resonates with people and uh
and so that was a really nice thing to
have so are you anticipating being the
janitor for this book for the next uh
five editions of it to keep up with
changes in the
software and github and technology and
dependencies and every other thing
i i i don't i hope not
we'll see i think i think there's sort
of um writing the book
helped me understand better what i was
interested in
in a from a broader perspective as well
in terms of supporting independent
creators and it helped me figure out
the thing that i wanted to focus on next
which is working at
a company that is focused on that and so
i think i want to continue
i certainly am not going to tire the
topic anytime soon but i want to look at
it from different angles besides just
open source and so
um yeah hopefully it's a public
contribution that other folks will
overflow what's the company you're
working with
uh it's a company called substack that
is a platform for
independent writers for people to send
out newsletters and
it's just it's been a really interesting
journey in thinking about
basically if uh open source developers
are trying to figure out how to get
paid full time um we're kind of tackling
a similar question for writers who are
also
um yeah i mean it's a really tough
question of like if i'm
a popular blogger or independent writer
how do i get paid full time to
to work on what i love and so yeah so so
much of
what went into the book i feel like i
apply all the time at work but
it's nice to think about a similar type
of problem but from a different
a different sort of angle i've got one
other question in the research i've been
doing i came across
a practice at google where they refer to
maintenance as
toil the stuff you have to just keep
doing over and over again
it's boring and it's tiresome and you
have to be careful and blah blah blah
and so what they're always looking for
is ways to use
better well to basically automate toil
to uh program in such a way that uh
the toilet isn't needed or that they can
now
uh put in a it amounts to a toil fix
is that something that uh software the
open source developers are doing it all
i'm curious how are they defining toil
um maintenance
uh janitor to work uh having to
you know constantly go and adjust the
relationship with dependencies and all
those
not fun things um like you know
you know internet explorer six god help
us that was toil
um and their work around which was
wonderful which is go out and kill
internet
explorer 6. but most cases
you got to keep screwing around with it
and
they reportedly what they do is is find
a way to automate that aspect of it
this is kind of what kevin kelly often
says is anything the robot can do
humans should not do so figure out more
things that robots can do so
humans can go on to the fun stuff any of
that going on with open source
yeah i think there's been a lot of
improved developer tooling over the
years and sort of streamlining of these
processes that have
helped make it easier to review
contributions and to understand what
what admin tuner needs to do on a
project so i'm thinking about
testing and continuous integration
which are sort of like these um defined
workflows for
for developers where say someone sends
you a contribution and you don't know
the person but
github for example or um will tell you
uh whether the the contribution breaks
the tests that you have set up in a
project where it's like oh if
i introduce this code then it's gonna
actually like cause problems in other
parts of my code
um and so i think things like that have
really helped
make life easier for developers and
there's probably so much more they could
be doing
um i remember when i was at github we
also uh there was a similar sort of
check or an automation for security
vulnerabilities in your project where
they would flag and let you know if
there were security volume rows and then
you would you would go in and review it
but at least
you didn't have to worry about like
going out there and finding that
information
and so yeah it is fun with developers i
feel like they're constantly trying to
automate themselves out of
the work they don't really want to be
doing so that's definitely like a
a big part of the culture i do wonder
sometimes similarly to the email problem
of how do we all manage too much email
um if you're certain streamlining some
of these processes are you actually just
sort of
making it uh and ultimately just
increasing your volume long term because
it's like oh now i can review 100
contributions and before i could only do
one
so who knows whether it's sort of like
net positive but
but it's definitely happening right well
i'm going to hand this off to kevin
all right thank you so much stuart and
i'm i'm curious um i mean you've studied
many types of infrastructure
and i think that you know we generally
think of things of like roads and
bridges
and these things that taxpayer dollars
go to but there seems to be very little
taxpayer dollars going to the open
source community do you see a future
where
um our tax dollars actually go to
maintaining some of our digital
infrastructure in a way that's similar
to roads and
bridges it's a really interesting
question um
it's one that i've grappled with and i'm
not sure where i land on it
um i mentioned this in the talk but like
we don't have a government of the
internet the way that we do for
physical jurisdictions and so there are
a lot of really interesting questions
around
um whose job is it to
like who's whose taxpayer dollars would
really go towards maintaining an open
source project
if you theoretically have contributors
from all over the world
and i've talked to maintainers of
projects who have grappled with these
questions around
um i live in a country where
the average salary is much higher than
my co-maintainer in a different country
um what does it mean for us to get paid
if we receive the sum of money how do we
actually divide that up
um and so yeah it's hard to think about
which government would really take
responsibility
responsibility for any one open source
project but i do wonder whether there
are things that
we could do from a policy perspective
that might make it more
appealing for people to contribute to
open source projects
either individual developers or
companies where you can imagine maybe
like tax breaks
for supporting an open source project or
making it easier for
an individual to take a lower salary or
lower pay to
work on something that is perceived to
be in the public good so
i'm sure someone who's more creative at
designing policy than i might might come
up with something there
but it's certainly a really interesting
complex problem for open source
yeah indeed and we'll bring kevin in
after this kevin kelly one of our
founders um but
yeah i always find it interesting for
instance that um you know
the idea that some things like our birth
and our death records and our things
that are maintained
by you know cities and counties and
states and and federal governments
um often we get sold these kind of
proprietary packages
of data management that they then get
trapped in
and the idea that that we would not put
these things in an open source format
that we all have access to
that has a deep future as well as you
know a deep past in formats
um is almost criminal to me this idea of
like you know that you would you would
impossibly entrust your civil
in you know data infrastructure to
something that's owned by a company
seems very odd
um and so you know i know that there's
some countries um that have even
mandated that these things be open
source and some some proprietary
companies that have even
um open sourced at least their for their
data formats
on if not the the software that
underlies it
so that at least you know in 100 years
if you're trying to access
death records or birth records that you
have a chance to do that
so we'll bring we'll bring kevin in to
give us
some other questions as well welcome
kevin kelly hi
hi hello so i really really
enjoyed your talk and it was a lot of
news to me
and i particularly enjoyed your emphasis
on the maintenance part rather than the
creation
which is what we usually hear about and
to the point of
xander's question about maybe using
taxation as a means
i was just wondering if um things like
unesco
cultural heritage i'm not sure who funds
unesco but there are all these sites
around the world that get money and
maybe
we could also take a similar attack with
these kinds of software projects and
declare them cultural heritages
that are being supported globally
in maybe a similar way that unesco um
sites are being
so just as there's a list of all the
unesco sites
some of these open sources could be
unesco cultural heritage that we support
globally that is such a cool idea that's
really extending the um
the conservation biology kind of thing
how do you conserve code and
in different kinds of ways and i guess
there's there's something there as well
i
when i think about the government and
open source sort of relationship i'm
often thinking about specific countries
but there are
also inter-governmental organizations um
like unesco that are
um that straddle other multiple
countries so
that's a really interesting idea that i
hadn't thought about
so speaking of countries i'm wondering
if you've noticed in your investigations
any kind of regional differences about
the attitudes towards either maintenance
or particularly maintenance of software
for instance japanese have a long
history of being really good at
maintenance and kind of
taking it very seriously i'm wondering
if open source
projects in japan are treated any
differently than other parts of the
country whether in asia
india or china you've seen
different attitudes or different
programs and
or whether or not this is you know like
github and other things
kind of an american-centric um
predominantly place where at least
it's being um managed so so is it
a truly global phenom and
or is are there regional differences
it's a really interesting question
when i think about regional differences
between
uh open source projects i'm often
thinking about language ecosystems which
i guess are
sort of like the digital version of our
countries that are kind of emerging for
software developers um and so open
source is uh definitely concentrated
among the united states europe and
australia
but we are seeing kind of growing hot
spots of
interest in china and in nigeria and so
it's um i think
that landscape will look very different
and in just a few years and it already
is starting to look very different
um and as you were talking about uh
japanese
uh open source developers i was thinking
about the origins of ruby
um where they do have this they're sort
of like a subculture within
um the ruby programming language uh
because it was started
uh it was authored by a japanese
developer and they have this um
this acronym called i think minisuan
which is mats is nice so we are nice
um math is the original author and so
they um they have this sort of like
cultural norm around uh we are nice to
each other because our
original founders was nice to each other
um and that might just be a function of
his personality more than culture i'm
not really so sure
uh but i do think there is sort of an
interesting parallel or analogy made of
um when we think about uh
cultural differences we're often talking
about different countries or geographic
regions in the physical world
but then in the digital world there's
sort of like definitely really strong
differences between
say a javascript developer and a closure
developer
and it's really just interesting to see
how some developers might
be more conservative in how they think
about maintenance whereas others sort of
lean into
giving every giving away control very
frequently or welcoming lots and lots of
different contributors
and it creates different types of
software as well where some software is
sort of like minimal but more tightly
bound whereas other software is very
like sprawling and wide and
i explore some of those things in in my
book but but i think there's a similar
parallel to be made there around
geographic distinction and
i have one last quick question which is
the internet explorer six
killing it off which is a brilliant hack
and i'm wondering
if there's been much discussion about
when you should let open source software
die
and um because people who are
maintaining
have kind of an interest in keeping it
going but it may not be the best for the
ecosystem so
is there good heuristics about
deciding when something should be let go
and
something new um started or um
how how that kind of things is decided
whether this is
just an organic or whether there's kind
of a a benchmark or
or something is it the consent of all
the other
software arising and you just go with
the flow i'm just wondering
when you are dedicated to maintaining
things how do you know when your time is
up
it's a really important question to be
to be discussing i think
there are a few different uh let's not
call them failure modes but sort of like
modes i guess where an open source
project might
um die or fade away that i can think of
one is just sort of a community loss of
faith in the maintainer maybe because
their behavior is not
desirable or they just sort of
disappeared and they're not very active
anymore
and so all the users are sort of need to
do something to
regain control of the project there's
another mode
where the the project is
maybe just sort of technically not as
state of the art as it could be and i
think those are maybe like the more
um complex questions because uh
all these projects are very like
interrelated with each other right so if
if everyone's software project is
pointing to one project and someone
wants to start a competing project it's
kind of
hard to say everyone start using this
other project because everyone is you
know
still still tied to the other project
and so it does require this very massive
shift in conversation to say
we should be using something else and
i've seen a few examples where
maintainers themselves will say
i'm sunsetting this project and i've
decided that this is not the newest
thing anymore i also don't really want
to maintain it anymore
and so you should use this other project
instead and that's maybe like the best
possible path right where
that's sort of collectively decided but
there are other situations where
everyone
is really tired of this project and they
wish there were a better alternative but
there isn't really any consensus or
movements to create something else and
yeah again i think it's just really
interesting to consider these governance
questions when you are talking in a
digital space and
not one with clear geographic
jurisdictions because um you might
if if we're talking about a public road
uh in
in the physical world there's you know
there's a government that is sort of
helping to decide whether we should
maintain that road or not
um online it's really uh it's kind of up
to developers to self-organize and
figure those questions out for
themselves so
i'd say it's different for every
language ecosystem every set of
developers but
a very important question well thank you
so much i really appreciate it
thank you for joining kevin um yeah and
we'll wrap up with a few
last questions here and i mean i think
one of the things i'd love to ask you
about you know both is kind of what are
you
where are you going next but also um you
know
you publish this with stripe press which
is a new publisher i should also
disclose their
sponsor of this series but they i think
they're
i'm curious as to why them and not some
of the other publishers that that
you might have have worked with is there
is there a new model that's happening
here
yeah i think there's an opportunity for
a new model and i think stripe press is
one of the most interesting examples
that we have right now um
i had when i thought about publishing
this work as a book i
uh was for me the most natural fit
seemed to be working with an academic
publisher because it was a reflection of
of research that i had done and i found
that as someone who
doesn't have a phd and had not gone
through sort of like the traditional
academic path
um it's actually pretty hard to both um
it's hard to find the the right uh
publisher to work with
partly because there's a question of
your credentials and sort of like well
who are you to be writing about open
source in the first place and i've
gotten a lot of that
um over the years from more traditional
institutions um
and then there's also just this this
question of um
do they really understand the problems
that are facing technology right now
and i think what is so interesting and
unique about straight press is that uh
they kind of sit between both these
worlds where both being a publisher they
are thinking about ideas and
um and they're looking for people that
are writing and researching about
interesting ideas to
uh to invite them to publish but on the
other hand they're tied to this company
and they're
very you know deep seated in the world
of technology and so
i think some of the most interesting
research can happen at that that sort of
um that border between practitioner and
um and
pure theory and uh and i think it would
be really great to see more things like
straight press where
um where we can sort of like source some
of the most interesting ideas that are
happening in
technology right now um i i felt like
it's uh
opens the the issue around open source
is something that
mostly software developers really
understand because they feel it all the
time
um and and uh yeah so strike price was
really just like the perfect partner for
that
nice and can you say a little bit about
what you might want to work on next i
know you're on vacation right now so you
don't have
i don't want to push you too much on the
spot but i'd love to hear if you have
thoughts of your future research
projects
yeah so i um i as mentioned
over the course of writing this book i
realized that there were so many
parallels between what was happening in
open source and what's happening
with content creators more generally i
had really only intended for this book
to be
about open source and then it was really
over the course of writing it that i
realized there it was
the gateway to so much more and so i
really wanted to be around that i wanted
to understand how online communities are
changing
and um it feels like there's so much
happening in the social web right now
where we are starting to see the
creation of
not just the most public social
platforms but these
smaller more intimate spaces and i just
wanted to be around that and so
i ended up joining this company called
substack to
focus on addressing this question of how
do we bring more
great independent writing into the world
how do we help writers make money
and so it does feel like switching
between this
sort of being very theoretically focused
uh while writing the book
to now thinking about how do we put
those things into practice in my
day-to-day job right now so
uh so that's sort of where my brain is
at right now and then we'll see what
happens after that
nice all right well and my last question
you know i really love this idea of
of changing the title of uh of the
people that work on these things
from maintainer to steward and and it
reminded me of kind of one of my
favorite stories about that is that
the um the person who maintains the
salisbury cathedral clock which is the
oldest continuously running clock
in the world that we have currently um
is that he's his title is called keeper
of the fabric
uh which i think is just the most
beautiful title um and it's amazing to
me like
and you can see in the interviews with
him like that that title changes the way
he thinks about what he does
um and i'd just love to hear a little
bit more about your thoughts on
on how titles can can change the way we
think about some of these maybe more
mundane tasks
definitely even there's even i think
over the course of
how the term container has evolved
there's another term core developer that
is often used and i think
the evolution towards maintainer was
helpful because it suggested that
this person is not just writing code but
doing a lot of things that are not about
writing code like
um maintaining their community and
reviewing contributions
um and so i i like that as sort of like
a first shift but then
i think uh yeah maintainer kind connect
often has this connotation of well no
one likes to maintain things even though
maintaining things is really important
and so yeah i love the idea of thinking
about stewardship or leadership or
something that is
um yeah this more reverent title around
this person is being entrusted with
thinking about this project in
the long term because right now i think
um when a developer feels like a
maintainer they feel like they got stuck
with it versus like oh i get to be the
maintainer or steward of this project
for the long run keeper of the fabric is
a pretty good one i can't really compete
with that
no i think it was mckenna who said like
you know when you use this term things
like maintainer or
or sustainability even like no one wants
to just sustain their marriage they want
like they want they want there to be a
much more exciting version of that so
like how do you uh how do you make that
an exciting and good term
and i think i'm sorry i will add one
more question i think one of the things
i did want to ask about is i mean you
you interviewed many many people on this
and
um what was the demographics of
the the people that are doing the the
maintenance of this i know there's i
mean
a lot of our software is written by one
very specific demographic
um that while the software is used by
everybody in the world
um and i'm curious as to you know how
that demographic looked to you as you
interviewed those people and maybe how
you see it going in the future
yeah it's really interesting i um
originally
just even just like having conversations
with developers you kind of you know
pick up on the demographics of the
people that you're talking to
um the when i was at github we actually
did a survey
of open source contributors to actually
put some numbers around this because
there are very few numbers around it at
all
and i was both shocked but maybe not
actually that surprised to find that for
example
um 97 percent of the people who
responded to that survey were
identified as male so you think about
sort of like the
the skewed demographics maybe in like
technology industry more broadly and
then
think about just sort of like a more
extreme version of that for in open
source
um i think there's an interest in
i felt that so many of the folks i
talked to were
extremely interested in broadening the
circle of people that can contribute to
open source and there's a lot of
really really great efforts around
onboarding
new types of contributors and mentoring
new maintainers and so
i know there's a lot of desire and
excitement around that um i think these
things
definitely take time but i'm feeling
optimistic and there's there's a lot of
reception and willingness and excitement
of um how to change that story around
for
for the future generation cool well
thank you so much for writing this book
thank you for joining us and thank you
for this talk
uh we look forward to hearing about your
future research
thank you so much all right and i want
to thank all of you
and our online audience and look forward
to our future talks that we have coming
up
thank you so much have a good evening